all right who was spring time maybe you
know spring is um if you don't know what
spring is it's when winter kind of gets
lazy and winter you know winter kind of
falls asleep at the wheel and and spring
starts to perk up you know spring is
that time you can hear um you could hear
flowers start to put deodorant on you
know they're about to that thing about
popping back out into the world showing
just flexing them petals baby you know
if you put your ear up to the snow right
now you can hear you can hear little
animals start to yawn a little you might
hear a chipmunk do it he's thinking
about popping out you know doing
something maybe looking for a little dip
monk you know him he's thinking oh i'ma
get out maybe you meet me a woman it's
that time almost
and that's spring if you think you know
you can hear you could hear water start
to kind of you know because you could
hear on a mountain you could hear a
mountain if you put your ear up to a
mountain you could hear it saying aw you
know what [ __ ] all these skiers and
snowboarders I'm about ready to drip out
make a stream and do something different
that's spring if you look in the up in
the trees sometime you could you'll see
a hole in a tree go peek in there and
you'll see a couple of birds in there
doing it wildly and doing um maybe doggy
style or something I don't know if birds
do doggy style that seems really but
that seems like the dark arts right
there but
it's that time of year you'll see uh you
know you'll see an otter kind of getting
out of a sleeping bag
a spring maybe it's here and I'm here
and so are you let's go
[Music]
and that's a little law that's that
beautiful ditty that's that beautiful
ditty and that's my tie nice and who and
tie nice and who's a well we don't know
what he is tie nice and who is a man who
makes melody somewhere in the great
beyond and he sent him to me through
email and in the old days now we have
email in the old days you may see a
donkey come up and a letter will fall
off of his back you may have a black
raven or something or a dark bird or
something you know a flamenco negro you
know fly by and just you know just spit
up a secret you know you then you didn't
and that evolved eventually you had the
u.s. postal system and everything and
now we have email which when you think
about it email it's a lot more direct
you know to think that in the old days
if you wanted to send somebody an email
you had to give it to a man who you
didn't know who may have been who knows
doing what you know he might have been
doing dope he might have been doing
uppers downers rounders whatever side
splitters he might have been doing
anything and trust that that bad boy was
gonna drop off the things you needed to
say to somebody else geez
that seems that seems old-school but uh
but now we got email and it's the direct
it's basically an electronic system that
says hey [ __ ] that other guy they used
to run it over there and that is a tie
nice and who who sent that in thank you
for that and that was a Valentine's Day
hitter he sent us and that's more than
words that's a cover of the famous song
more than words and in tiny also we'll
put a link at the bottom too you can
check out some of his other stuff
another
things he sent over over the time period
of this podcast and he was a man he's a
secret man would never met him never
seen him and what is he when you think
of a tiny sand - it could be anything it
could be a man it's four inches tall and
where's uh you know Birkenstocks and
jumps you know and he has a guitar on
the ground he's as jumps from from he
jumps from chord to chord and does it
all with his feet
he could be you know he could be
something as secret as that that's tiny
sand whoo and and I'm here man I'm
making it through the day
thawing out bro winter we we trying to
get you to give up Big Daddy because I
have more of a body type that's I don't
know if I had that winter body type you
know I got that thick upper crust you
know I have the uh everybody knows I got
the heart of a lesbian my father told me
that when I was very young and even
wrote it one time at a napkin on a bar
over there at Tony Pedone E's bar and
over at the stink and onion which were a
couple of small outfits over there near
us in Covington Louisiana he would write
it on the napkin to remind me a couple
of things about myself I needed to
remember and I have also you know I got
this that thick up or I got that thick
that uproar that top that girdle you
know I'm front axis I'm two wheel
driving it so I'm front I'm front wheel
drive you know if you say if you put my
body in the shop the guy would be like
where the hell is the back wheels being
god I'm daddy we ain't got him my torque
is up top because I have that chest it
looked like if you look like I took a
like a big inhale and never let it out
like I was smelling something and just
never decided what what never could
figure out what I smelled and so I've
never let it go I've always been like
that I've always had that
just that girthy that forthright kind of
those tit fields you know the chest and
the torso I'll probably have 6070 ribs
in me you know I know I've said it
before but if you beat me open you'll
hear you know you'll definitely have a
yah
you'll have a black family show up at a
park but a bag of briquettes baby
because it's time to grill you know when
Daddy when they split me open because
I'm gonna feed the world baby with these
ribs so but happy springtime Thank You
tiny for that hit thank you for dropping
just that audio right into us more than
words I just got back I was in Oroville
and we went down over there myself and
re manis and man we we got at it over
there they're one of the oldest Chinese
food restaurants 10:1 fook over there
and then people ain't ten one [ __ ]
around dog they got that old brother
they got [ __ ] Raven they got you know
Raven ribs up in there you go in there
they got a damn you could have half a
batwing and some orange marmalade bro $6
dog right out the gate the you you can
have a Chinese lady come up and just
spit in your mouth for half a dollar
what is that bro and you could get that
super fortune cookie at the end dude
some guy comes out with a [ __ ] blade
pokes you in the ass and tells you a
secret brah I never knew my sister like
damn okay and that's five bucks that's
that finisher it's that kind of place
man they got the oldest I think I said
it's 115 years old a Chinese food there
so if you want to fill your mouth with
that you know with those the original
you know something that's just fresh off
the boat man you could taste the salt
water in then that's the place over
there to get into that but we had fun
over there I got some shows coming up
I'm gonna let you know right now
February 20th 21st and 22nd this coming
weekend I'll be in Toronto February 27th
Red Bank New Jersey February 28th Oxon
Hill Maryland February 29th Newport News
Virginia
that's almost sold out everything else
is sold out and then we got the castle
theater out there and Kahului Hawaii and
that is going to be March 7th and that's
what it is maybe that's what it is I've
got to let you know - man is this
episode is brought to you by blue chew
and look everybody's got that wiener
that doesn't want to commit to an
erection everybody's got it rarely do
you see a man with the full meet that
men of yesteryear had I mean you debt
your granddaddy you if he heard a
woman's name if he saw a woman's name
written on a wall when he was driving by
it he'd he'd spring meat
he'd pop beef brother we can't do that
now we don't have it the DNA we have now
where you know everybody's doing more
online gaming modern warfare than they
can people see their wife and they say
oh look can we just do modern warfare
instead of do you know do that freakin
bot that low body attack sex well do you
remember the days when you're always
ready to go now you can increase your
performance and get that extra
confidence in bed and anywhere really
you could take your meat everywhere as
long as your legs are working blue
chicom that's blue like the color blue
blue Chu brings you the first chewable
with the same fda-approved ingredients
as Viagra and Cialis
cialis you could take him anywhere
daytime nighttime hell you could be in a
time machine and pop two of them [ __ ]
bruh and show up in the 1800s with that
magic wand blue chew is prescribed
online by licensed physicians so you
don't have to go to the doctor or wait
in line at the pharmacy and lie
oh these are for my cousin manager for
my stepdad dude you ain't by him [ __ ]
dick hitters for your step daddy brother
not and it ships right to your drawer in
a discrete package they're made in the
USA and since blue chip repairs and
ships direct they're cheaper than a
pharmacy right now we got a special deal
for our listeners because we want you to
have strong meat visit blue chew comm
and get your first shipment free when
you use our special promo code just pay
$5 shipping again that's blue2 dot-com
promo code Theo to try it it's free
blue chew the better cheaper faster
choice and we thank them for sponsoring
the podcast oh yeah the XFL is going on
I know Nick went to a game producer Nick
went to again maybe I'll get him in here
in a little bit and we'll talk about it
what did I do yeah we went up terrible
and we got into it they had a lot of
people came out Nancy came out this lady
tall Nancy and she had a day I'm uh she
did a homemade sweater I forgot to get a
picture of it and said gang on the front
that was beautiful we had two fellows
came out one of them had a that they
were brothers and when I'm had a nervous
condition and they had a arm when I'm
had an HC on a brown hermit crab and he
showed me that bastard run that was
beautiful so I love that if somebody
especially a beautiful thing is to sneak
up head in and after the show if we're
doing you know meet-and-greet or hanging
out show that yeah that's surprise pet
but spring is in the air it's that time
and it thinks you know this is when the
window window the things that we were
thaw out you know this is the time when
uh
Prospera this prosper is in the air
there's possibility you know something
could happen man you spit a sunflower
seed out of a car window in four years
later you could have a beautiful day I'm
half a bouquet right there
because that's this time of year there's
fertility is in the soil new you can
masturbate behind a damn 7-eleven and
who knows but you might show up [ __ ]
9 years later and you got a you know a
kid that's never been to kindergarten
back there so there's possibility man
there's you know there's possibility for
some new things right now and that's
built in that's built into what the
world that's crazy isn't it and then
while I imagine if you were one of the
first people ever you know and I don't
know who they were probably Indians or
Native Americans you know who knows man
probably could have been anybody dude
probably a white guy wearing like a
cheetah or you know couple brothers out
there doing something exotic bird doing
some wearing some seashells and stuff
over there fronts but imagine you were
out there early times and winter
happened you had no idea you thought
things were going well and then BAM dude
everything's frozen
you'll white you for everybody and then
BAM again springtime tada
is back so that's really something could
you even imagine the first time at first
nobody's like Oh moon the World's End
and it's over blue I'm cold
you know Janet's frozen and then BAM boy
to hit you with that surprise springtime
that opportunity for something new
we had some calls that came in yeah
what's going on I'm trying to think
about in my world you know I remember I
was thinking this week about kissing you
know when you kiss somebody and kissing
his wing you put your mouth against
somebody else and that's I could only
imagine the first time somebody said
you let me know if you feel anything
about this and then they just did it you
know somebody said hey let me just put
my mouth against your face or something
your neck bra and see if you feel
something and I wonder if you did it on
a wall you know some dude probably
started trying it on his buddy who was
nervous like hey let me try it on you a
couple times and then I'll run over
there to Dorothy you know so some guy
maybe had a real nice friend and he let
him try that let him just try that Peck
that pepper just sprinkling that
pepperoni all over him just just kind of
nibbling on his neck because you had to
practice somewhere you know you had to
practice kissing nobody goes right out
there first on and just drops that face
on us somebody else what who you Ted
Bundy do you can't do you got to
practice and dude I remember when I was
young we would get like a pillow you
know and my buddy and I'm just gonna say
his middle name Patrick he would come
over and we would get these pillows do
them we would lay next to him and just
be like erotic you know and in our
bodies man my body would get so hard
right in the middle dude god I just
didn't know what was going on and I
didn't know that the devil and God were
just fighting inside of my penis at the
time and it would just be so and the
first time we were supposed to just be
kissing our pillows my buddy would lay
over on my brother's bed cuz my brother
wasn't living with us and I would lay on
my bed and we're supposed to just be
kissing our pillows and pretending there
were these girls that we liked but 9
seconds into we do you know what I'm
saying
things have escalated you know we go on
a second base third base fourth base
fifth base six base you know then you
got Pedro Martinez beating the [ __ ] out
of Tommy Lasorda you know what I'm
talking about boy young bucks just
you know just vibrating against the
pillow man just in your body man you had
so much my god dude I could Hotwire a
damn dude I could Hotwire one of those
you know those little carousels outside
of a um outside of a grocery not gonna
Hotwire one of them [ __ ] with my with
the just the vit rasa tea that was in my
damn pecker at the time my buddy would
come over we would just practice on them
but then you had to do kissing you know
and like it you practice on the pillow
but someone wasn't enough and in
Lousiana day it's an oyster country you
know certain areas have a different
animal you know certain places you have
a different type of animal Oregon you
got a little maybe a woodchuck doing
something he's over there you know he
have a toothpick in his teeth and he's
picking wood out of his teeth because
he's been chucking it like dude this is
a real double entendre go to UM Spoon
River Illinois and you got a damn
catfish that bullhead maybe just
swimming and you know how a catfish
happened man a cat and a fish dude that
bad time
don't think panic and then think Dan and
Dan that's why they kind of he's got to
be careful when you let these animals
cross pollinate you know because it it
gets to crate if I let me tell you this
if a Falcon and a bumblebee do sex
that's gonna be lights out for the rest
of us bro
imagine a falcon shows up with that
powerful I ask baby that's gonna be
risky but I'm saying every place had a
different animal you got a different
animal here you got a bullhead catfish
over there in Illinois you know up in
Wisconsin they got that little milk
snake you know you go down to on Nevada
they got a us
scorpion you know they got ms-13 down
there you know you go to um Philadelphia
they got brotherly love they got what
else they got a couple real pasty white
dudes and I'm in a Darren Sproles Jersey
you know every place has their animal
and so the animal I'm thinking of what
was I talking about oh so in Louisiana
we had oyster and we would practice
kissing man we would get an oyster and
you get it open man and then you got to
get it out of there and I always felt
bad taking oyster out of his little
house and I felt kind of bad about this
[ __ ] I remember one time we went over to
the Presbyterian Church and I told that
man I said man and we've been taking his
oysters out and and pretending they were
tongues and kissing them you know and
that dude honestly man I think no joke I
remember I think that preacher told me I
was piece of [ __ ] but he also I think he
kind of winked at me a little bit so you
know fifty-fifty but uh but that was
what we would do we would get that
oyster and you practice because you
could put oyster oyster in your hand
like it was a tongue and so you throw
that always trying to microwave for
about 11 seconds you can get it warm
enough put it in your hand and you could
practice the kissing and God I mean it
wasn't ideal but it was way better than
kissing on your buddy's neck a little
but that was you remember kissing
practicing kissing how'd you practice
hit the hotline let me know how you
practiced kissing nine eight five six
six four nine five zero three because we
practice a couple ways man my one friend
he would come over this boy Jeremy and
he was born with some different
deficiencies but he popped through and
we put a bunch of perfume on his neck
and then kind of practiced kissing a
little bit but not not gay not like in a
gay way we even put a bag over his head
and draw like a woman on the sides
the bag you know and you can still smell
the perfume you could practice you know
pretend oh hey Katie or hey Charlotte
you know hey Regina you know hey Chandra
what's up and then you could practice
you know kissing but the big thing was
to get that oyster and heat that thing
up in the microwave for 11 seconds get
that thing tongue temperature and then
you would practice just but man I
remember that being young bro god man
and you just Lord you just lay I
remembered us laying outdoors sometimes
and just just just just thinking about
all the women that probably wanted to
have sex with me oh Jesus Christ
anyway man we got a lot of calls at uh
and a lot of those women most of those
women never never really did so but hey
look I thought it man I thought it I put
the thoughts out there I planted the
seeds out into the universe baby
it's seeding time it's spring get out
there put something new in the dirt try
something different
tell somebody take a chance you know you
know I'm tired of my own life I just I'm
tired of sometimes not taking some
chances I don't take a lot of chances
really I don't want to take some chances
I want to say I want to put something in
the ground I want to say hey you know
I'm tired of just rambling out here in
the wind I'm tired of sucking on oysters
I'm ready for some real tongue you feel
me gang let's take a call that has come
in I'm gonna let you know as well though
that this past weekend is brought to you
by Skillshare Skillshare and look we
talked about the Skillshare is one of
our premier primary sponsor and look
this is the thing if you don't have a
skill now's the time
get a skill you can't show up somewhere
without a skill what can you do and you
just don't do anything people would say
what's your hand me your resume and you
just had them just a piece of paper with
nothing on you just put your name a
couple times on it in different fonts
you got your name printed um scripture
and then helvete Helvetica you wingding
in your [ __ ] at the bottom what do you
have you don't have a skill my man skill
share is an online learning community
for creators creators with more than
25,000 classes and design business and
more you'll discover countless ways to
fuel your curiosity creativity and
career they have all kind of classes
mobile photography creative writing
illustration you can learn all of that
you could become somebody who does
social media for someone in a heartbeat
just spend a little time plan a little
seed whether you're looking to discover
a new passion start a side hustle or
gain new professional skills Skillshare
is there to keep you learning thriving
and reaching those new goals are you a
freelancer try bookkeeping for
freelancers how to handle your finances
join the millions of students already
learning on Skillshare today with a
special offer just for our listeners get
two months of Skillshare for free that's
right Skillshare is offering this past
weekend listeners two months of
unlimited access to countless classes
over 25,000 go to skills share comm
slash Theo von again go to Skillshare
comm slash Theo von to start your two
months now
that's Skillshare comm slash Theo von
I'm going to give an update yeah we uh
we did we we I want to thank everybody
that came out in the past to the
Lafayette show the fundraiser we we
raised $10,000 at night for the good
fight foundation and for a couple single
moms we treated a couple single moms um
helping them out and uh and just wanted
to say thank you to everybody that came
out to that and also we're gonna get a
bench for Billy conforto y'all remember
him and my friend
and goddamn he was beautiful guy you
know he had arms like uh he had arms
like damn [ __ ] just like Italian
antiques bro he had beautiful my god
like his arms came over on a boat from
damn Greece or somewhere somewhere
really Italian and he uh you know and he
was probably he was probably the
toughest gay male boxer in America in
the world even I put him up against
anybody who was the other guy Tommy Gunn
or whatever
not a chance boy Tommy slingshot Billy
Comfort I would put that put that boy in
the sand whoever he was I mean he you
know and we're gonna do a bench for him
with the funds that we made from moms
from the t-shirts that we sold for him
we're gonna do a bench over there and a
lot plus maybe at a dog park or
something cuz he loved those animals and
and he's always in our hearts man I love
you brother
and I miss you man gang and we're gonna
release some I'll put a we got a video
made we'll put up on patreon from that
Lafayette show so you guys be able to
check that out and thank you to
everybody who supports this past weekend
and that means you whether you do it
with your ears or or by supporting our
patreon or just by or anything I mean
the support that has been a part of this
podcast is one of the things I want to
try and focus more on and the rest of
this coming year and sometimes I'm own
life you know just gotten it I mean it's
a blessing and a curse you know the
because of the podcast and stand-up
things getting so busy that it's been
hard to focus sometimes on the things
that uh that mean the most to me which
is being a part of other people's lives
or being a part of a group you know when
I was on stage this weekend and
and I just felt like I just felt like
man I'm just so lucky to be part of a
group of people that are so loving you
know the people that come out to the
shows Menace especially the you know to
to our show to my show - the show - when
they come out the staff will constantly
say man this is the nicest group of
people we've had in a long time and and
that's one I just realized that's the
most important that's what's just so
important to me and that's what makes me
that's when I feel my best is you know
there's a lot of dirt there's a lot of
dandruff in the world but but just focus
for you know when I'm focusing on the
style baby when I'm focusing on that
when I'm focusing on that sweet
headpiece and I'm not worried about that
dirty dandruff you know there's a lot of
dandruff in the world but I know um but
there's a lot of sugar too and I feel
better when I've got that sugar on my
mind and yeah just you know I just
remember you know just just thank you
guys that it's just nice to be reminded
of what's important and that is each
other and and yeah I'll just I'm just so
glad to be here today and I'm glad that
um that you are here and that we haven't
given up on each other bro gang we've
got some calls that came in man who
knows what's gonna be in these dirty
boxes let's get to a couple right here
here we go Giovanni this is you we're
going to Toronto to see you for my
fiance's birthday right on the 21st oh
and thank you for that brother Toronto
is beautiful and Toronto the kind of
place great posture you see somebody you
barely see them because there's such a
straight perpendicular
you know a straight vertical people
constantly they're false
directly into potholes because they're
so you know somebody has a hurt back or
one of their arms out in a weird way
they hit up they flip in a pothole they
get caught but with that Toronto posture
baby this disappearance son disappearing
right into the dang birdbath of hell
baby them potholes them city holes gang
brother home word and I have a question
we actually saw you in California in
July when I proposed and she developed a
crush on you and I'm worried that when
we see you again for a real lengthy trip
show the dark edge to her that she's
gonna fall in love with you for real for
real hard and I mean it's a privilege
and an honor but I mean I don't know how
I'd handle that so you can let me know
anyways was he in Toronto in the 21st
steel run take care gang brother and
look I'm not responsible if your lady
get you know you show up you know you
show up with a lady and she leaves and
look you know and her her breasts grow
two sizes while she's at the show that's
a side effect of seeing Papa what I'm
gonna do you know I can't help it if you
know she'll bring her to the show y'all
leave the show and suddenly she knows a
couple new sexual tricks you know y'all
go back to the room she got to wig or
something when she got that you know
she's got on a four-piece outfit with uh
you know tassels and stuff over the
crotch and all look that's a side effect
baby
the dark arts you got to be careful if
you that's the thing if you if you're
gonna go near a wishing well at night
don't be shocked if you wake up with a
little something pitching and yes in the
morning you filming Brum don't be
shocked if you you know your lady what
you know wakes up knowing how to uh you
know crochet your arm they a pentagram
do not be shocked it's the dark arts
tour man and it's still going do nothing
in September October and October I
believe it'll be too this tour will be
almost two years we're far from there
though and there's only a few shows left
I keep saying that but but yeah bring
your lady out come on out and I'm
excited to see you guys and I'll do my
best brother - nada infiltrate I'll -
simple treat your heart brother and I
stop right there nine eight five six six
four nine five zero three is the hotline
as always let's get to another call or
two here we go anything else Ramsay and
what's up Ramsay and that's a name out
of the Bible Ramsay or Egypt and
basically Egypt was just a Bible on land
if you want to look at it like that you
know the Middle East they got a lot of
sand Christians over there - people
think it's just Slim's over there and um
in bruges bro but it ain't they got a
lot of SC's over there baby I'm saying
Chris Jones and that is uh that's your
boy Ramses over there hot off the
Euphrates dog gang son homework 1600
when I was 17 my mom passed away didn't
really I never met my dad or anything he
took up oh I'm sorry to hear that man
I'm sorry to hear that uh that that
happened to you such a young age
brother homeward it's been on my own
since then and over over that period of
time I've been able to like you know
I've been I've been having some ups and
downs you know just because of the
instability but silly man things been
going alright you know I got a
girlfriend that alone and I've got
friends around me and it's great it's
great but you know that era always gives
me worried because my entire been I've
been dealing with you know in anxiety uh
something's about to go wrong so yeah I
just wanted to know what your what your
thought is on that you know how
your mind from telling you everything's
about to blow up so for the government
well I appreciate you getting gang bro
man it's so funny to you that you called
him first of all thank you for calling
there Ramsay's brother and it's so funny
call and ask about this because this has
been on my mind recently I've been
realizing that I have you know in you
know working in AI working you know I
mean I don't work in I'm in you know
12-step program and I always have to
call my you know sponsor my friends and
just ask them is everything okay cuz I
don't know there's something inside of
me that everything is not going to be
okay all the time and that's why I'm
always having to do stuff because
everything nothing feels stable and some
my mind's always like oh you better you
got to do this you got to do this you
got to do this because something's not
you know so I would just you know what's
helped me recently is for me I don't
know if this could be work for you but
for me what has helped is just asking
somebody on a regular basis Hays
everything's okay right and they just
say yeah man everything's okay I say
okay so I have this feeling like
everything is not okay and it's just
been there my whole life and sometimes I
don't even realize it I don't even know
that this thing was there you know but
but I'm here to tell you man I think a
lot of that comes from just the end like
you're saying the instability just the
uncertainty that things something's
going to go wrong for me it's not that
as much as something is going to go
wrong as much as it is that uh that
something has to be done that something
is wrong something isn't done something
is not okay and and it's really an
intense anxiety it's one that's built
down into us it's like somebody had a
treasure chest but no treasure in it
just anxiety and they put that [ __ ]
deep in us
and one thing that has helped me is is
talking to my sponsor talking to my
friends in and saying hey just tell me
that everything is okay you know is
everything ok and they'll answer yes
sometimes they even get frustrated with
it but I need to hear it I just need to
hear it on a regular basis that
everything is ok because I think as a
child just no one told me it was you
know when everything felt wrong and
everything felt messed up and you know
no one ever said hey everything is OK
no one ever said it and if you have
children look I don't have children you
know I don't know what that's like but I
do know what it's like to have been one
and I think you know you know it just I
think it helps them to hear that
sometimes just for no reason at all just
you know just hug your kid and just say
hey you know everything is OK you know
[Music]
you know you might not think it is or
sometimes you may feel like things
aren't but I'm just here to remind you
that everything is you know I think if
they have that voice bouncing around in
them that's the sugar baby that's not
the dander if you feel me but thanks for
that call man and keep your head up out
there in a gang brother let's hit
another call here what we got poppin off
bro
as always the hotline nine eight five
six six four nine five zero three thank
you
oh and don't forget hit the calls with
when you uh how did you practice kiss
him when you were young did you have you
know did you did you bag up your boy
with that gender different sandwich sack
over his head you know you draw Melanie
on the front of that bag and just go to
town on your boy what did you do did you
practice on a pillow get you a lobster
how'd you do it huh ninety five six
sixty four nine five zero three here we
go
I feel what does with me fat man from
Santa Cruz California what's up Pat from
Santa Cruz well imagine how cool it must
be to grow up in a place like that a
place that have crews in the name of it
could you imagine that
a place that have crews dude I had some
friends from a place called Big Branch
that was the name of the place big
branch so you know what was happening
around there boy nothing onward I woke
up this morning and uh thought I was
having a heart attack and basically went
to uh the emergency room and they told
me I had scoliosis man was I ever
relieved to know that I wasn't numbing
my chest because my chicken was bad it
was uh basically uh born with scoliosis
man and pinched a nerve and made me feel
like I was gonna have a heart attack but
I got tagged what man you make me laugh
all the time caught you in comedy few
months back and dude
praise the Lord feel alright man how
gang bro
now scoliosis I'm look I'm glad you're
well and you sound if you well enough to
leave a voicemail you're doing alright
do we had a guy when I was growing up
and in in college he would get all high
I mean and by he I mean all of us and we
would smoke at all bro we smoke whatever
that's back when you they didn't have as
much weed now they got all kinds of
different weed you know they got [ __ ]
euthanasia is a strand they got left leg
they got some [ __ ] died you know kill
your cousin is a new strand like what is
that you know I'm trying to have a
family reunion and everybody's got to
mounts as to kill you cuz this singing
to him well but this dude would get so
high man he had one of his mom
one of those stroke things she couldn't
talk or something were not talk but
she'd done so many Winston's that she
blew her throat out so she had had that
little law you know that thing like that
um she had to put that thing up to her
throat and he got so high that he would
have to use that [ __ ] he couldn't talk
so he'd get his mom's little case you
know when she was asleep he'd get the
case and he bring that thing with them
that little safety case when we would
smoke out so we'd be blazed up man
I mean higher than the damn Chicago Fire
and this do he'd be like Bargo balls hit
ball I set my Wendy's that's the only
thing he could use was that law
let's hit the windy my mom so we knew
when he opened that case up that he was
baked out his Oreos was double-stuffed
bruh oh man I need a ride home he would
have to use that little electric thing
bruh oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
but man if you got scoliosis how the
hell did it take you so long to
recognize it papa that's a children's
disease and everybody remembers
scoliosis man and everybody had a
different you know
remember school when you were young you
had to go to school because nobody
trusted you were just maybe going to be
smart and like every four years at
school they would take everybody into
the cafeteria and take their shirts off
and I remember the first time I went I
was like damn there's some real German
type of [ __ ] but and they would have you
bend forward and show that little back
BZ baby that backbone you know you'd
have to freakin hit that dolphin bruh
and the lady would stand there Miss
Waskom or miss Connaughton or miss
whoever you know miss Barbara she would
stand
there and she would take a marker man
she would take a marker and just draw it
straight down your back oh he's good
this one checks out
you know he's straight he could go you
know back to learning and then they had
like a one group I guess if you had
scoliosis which I thought it sounded
good they're like oh we're gonna see who
has scoliosis I'm like oh [ __ ]
I hope I got it dude I'm sharing a
bedroom with my brother you know I'm
ready for a life change but but it
wasn't it was like your spine had that
little hiccup you know your spine got a
little wander II in the middle a [ __ ]
got a little Hansel Hansel Gretel you
know your spine kind of went missing on
itself a little you know your spine kind
of wandered off into the woods over
there by one of you you know your spine
kind of did a little detour around one
of your lungs or something now and so
they do everybody and anybody had that
little wah you know had that HOV Lane on
their backbone and couldn't you know hit
that Dolph and they'd draw the little
crook on her back with the marker and
put him in that special area I don't
know what happened to those kids man and
Daniel do it everybody knows Daniel bro
he I remember one time he took his shirt
off and they had his spine and him had
the damn uh it went in a damn pentagram
like well well that he ain't he couldn't
be real healthy so but you know Daniel
Manny's I'm not shocked he probably
shifted his spine into that shape by
himself because he's guy he makes his
own choices man he made his own choices
but I'm glad that you I mean if you had
a childhood disease this long you I'm
glad you're getting on top of it you
might want to get also check for them so
el coyol parks baby them chickenpox and
what else Oh getting a splinter that's
another thing kids hate but I'm glad
you're well brothers stay safe man I've
got to let you know that today's episode
brought to you by cap Tara
what if you could make your work take
less work Oh wouldn't it be nice
wouldn't that be nice it's something you
can do look at your job see what it is
do it in less time well you can with
kaptara kaptara helps you find the right
software for your needs fast so you can
get back to business
even faster compare thousands of
software options read reviews and
instantly narrow your favorites you'll
have more time in no time find the right
software right now at kaptara calm /
Theo and guys we want everybody to
support the podcast if you can if you
find an ad that fits you and it's
something you need would love you two to
be supportive kaptara is the leading
free online resource to help you find
the best software solution for your
business with over 1 million reviews of
products from real software users
discovering everything you need to make
an informed decision search more than
700 specific categories of software
everything from project management to
email marketing to yoga studio
management software and that kind of
stuff I'm sorry you know we we've got a
crew that's working over here now with
this past weekend and King in the sting
and so I need to get some help with the
time management and making sure
everybody's timing is all clean and
clear and what days they've worked
kaptara c.a.p ter are a.com slash theo
for free today to find the tools to make
an informed software decision for your
business CA p ter are a.com slash theo
that's kaptara comm slash theo kaptara
software selection simplified let's get
into another call here homework your boy
Anthony from okay what's up ant down
there in the OC man and I bought it I
bought a UH I bought some
came from a guy down there one time I
don't know what happened to him he did a
little bit of pornography and he had
every time I saw me a very drastically
um different haircuts homeward waiting
for you to hit that brave and proud girl
just waiting let us know um you're gonna
we're gonna get him stack hitter quick
question
I'll be trying to eat house and stuff
way to talk on call us our pizza and
that impossible burger I just want to
know what it what a guy like you has to
say about those items let me yeah thank
you for this question there and down
there beachside in the OC cauliflower
pizza and [ __ ] man that's pizza it could
be anything on peachy only getting four
pieces of it five pieces you know when I
was young least acted on there what do
you want on the pizza black olives the
pizza was so damn black man you didn't
even know you might find it in a you
know a Tom at essence Fest you know they
what you want on their sausages mm
little sausages now you get a pizza they
got nine sausages they set just far
enough away from each other so that none
of them infringing on the other ones
territory they're all in a safe space
it's like everybody gets the same little
amount it's like basically that Bernie
has that Bernie Sanders style so I think
you if you want to eat healthy you got
to eat healthy get things that are
living man get you a little something
get you a little arm you know uh have a
crab look at a look at a crab bra look
at a crab the meaning that thing so
fresh so nasty brush some naughty
imagine being a crab dude and all you
want to do is hug somebody but you got
them dangerous ass arms imagine that
imagine every night I better crab dreams
of just having soft arms where he could
touch a you know where he could you know
stroke a woman's hair without giving her
a crew-cut or where he could you know
you know touch a breast without having
to you know do I um enough a cave a
first-aid kit you know imagine that
imagine a crab just wishing he had soft
arms and then he wakes up and every time
he got those just cold-hearted snakes
bra they're mice cold frickin clip
digits he's got just carpal tunnel seven
thousand every single time what was your
question man I came in what you're
asking about cauliflower pizza uh
yeah bro get you something fresh get a
greenery get a greenery item get a kale
bunch get all broccoli get a little um
you know uh sweet potato get something
for yourself that's good that's fresh
man you got here eating pizza impossible
burger burger is a nice thing to have
maybe twice a week have you a burger but
the rest of the time take care of
yourself get some things in you I'm
having her dang roar organic and fused
drink right now low electrolytes keep a
lot of water in your body it's easy
stuff your body's 94% water and you out
here drinking damn uh you know you out
here drinking um code Reds Mountain Dew
what get you some water
but yeah you got to stay healthy man get
you some stuff that's good what I like
to do now get me a peppers give me a
different peppers pepper come in
different colors if you don't like
certain color peppers then make other
ones get a red get a green get on orange
get a yellow cat damn it just sup I
freaking introduced them [ __ ] to
Japan boy I take a knife to them noxious
you know I'll take that manscape trimmer
to them [ __ ]
you you you and I put me some cut some
beef cuts in the skillet and heat me up
them bc's baby throw them peppers in let
them things meet each other you know get
that proverbial that little skillet bang
going and then I serve them to myself
treat myself right gang let's take
another call here the hotline nine eight
five six six four nine five zero three
onward oh I gotta I gotta say we we want
to have an illegal alien on the podcast
so if you have a friend who is an
illegal alien in America illegally we're
not trying to out them or get them in
any trouble or anything like that we
just want to just see what their life is
like you know some roots real curious
about what that existence is like here
what it's like to just be that DL human
you know not to be confused with DL
Hughley so if you have if you have
something like that let us know now
don't send us some phony you know some
you know some BS but we want somebody
real they got to speak good English have
a good personality and and they came
over here illegal illegal into Estados
Unidos and you know
yeah I'm just super curious about what
that life is like you notice to be on
that constant hide-and-seek or if it's
like that at all so gang brother oh here
we go homework well that's you know a
longtime listener first-time caller
always wanted to say that big there you
show them in and I seen revolves around
solutions that's kind of what I'm
calling about man I could use a solution
probably a little off topic and a little
random but I'm a zookeeper man I work
with animals I've been doing this for
about ten years
wow wow man thank you for calling man
that's crazy
you're like a Jumanji guy
Wow boy oh man thank you for calling us
who keep our own word and I'm having a
hard time if I know the place I can stay
mega long still restored standards
I think people got low standards man
I've worked for roadside zoos I've
worked for big zoos kind of done it all
in between Aquarians trains for movies
oh yeah query on that wet zoo bro going
rehab rescue but I have a hard time
finding a place with good standards oh
yeah an animal rehab I can't even
imagine that you got a couple Gophers in
there on the lauded or something you
know you got maybe you might have a
muskrat in there who's been scratching
too much musk you feel me he was on em
80-milligram oxys bra emojis gang over
you think it's a choice to take care of
animals and we got to make a choice to
do right by them and too often I think
mistakes happen and I just think some
things need a little more structure a
little more rules we need a little more
everybody needs to tighten up you know
these animals are our mercy and so I
don't know man I'm just I'm thinking
about hanging it up and thinking about
the only other thing I've ever done is
construction think about throwing that
construction work I just don't know what
else to do but I love my animals I love
working with them and it's been a long
time to get to where I am and I'd hate
to give it up but I just I feel like I'm
I'm losing myself I feel like I'm
settling with my own morals and my own
conviction just to fit in and get along
and I like that something feel good so
again I appreciate what you're doing
brother gang gang gang man wow wow man
dude I would love for you to get to get
the proper uh you know me and Brendan
Schaub
he you know he's from King in the sting
you know him and he's a decent man and
he has very his hair is very nice as
nice hair and he has a jewelry and
everything but he and I almost invested
in a zoo down there and sent a lower
Sinaloa
but uh anyway some [ __ ] went wrong but I
would love to see you have your own zoo
and have you to have you see you be the
example you be the one that do that does
it because that's really where you know
change kind of comes from as that it's
like yeah nowadays everybody wants you
know they had a special on television
black sheep not black sheep but black
dolphin and they had a killer whale down
there and um down near San Diego and I
guess that a black dolphin is Welling I
guess it was I don't know if it was
about slavery I don't know what it was
about dude you got to watch it but
everybody's like all they're treating
animals bad and they're treating animals
like this look it's hard to treat an
animal great I think especially with all
the laws and everything you know
everything keeps getting haywire some
lady you know some ladies little son
falls in a damn zoo cage and they filed
a lawsuit well what's your son doing in
there how about that so the lawyer and
all the legalities ruin a lot of things
brother but that's when somebody comes
along and says I'm going to do this the
right way and that could be you you know
you could have Terrance's little magical
zoo at the you know could be zoo and ice
cream or something you know pet you a
koala and get a rocky road
you know what I'm saying tickle a real
Elmo and then get you that mint
chocolate chip pansy you could have you
know you could you could mix and match
so I think there's an opportunity there
for you to then do something special
whenever the you know it's tough though
sometimes also when you're arts or
something you really enjoy when it
becomes a job at a certain point it does
burn you out it burns you out man
there's a such a balance to everything
in there man is when the art becomes
such a job it can get burnt you can burn
you down
you know I feel exhausted sometimes from
you know workouts so busy that sometimes
I feel exhausted you know sometimes I
feel well I need my passion back you get
caught up too much in the X's and O's
and you forget the smell of the grass
you know and that's how I think we you
know you have to you have to find a way
to represent it to yourself or get you a
little animal get you a lemur bro get
you a little marmoset get you with
something do get you six caterpillars
and and do something you know get nine
crickets and train them [ __ ] to do a
stunt you know get a circus Mouse dog
one quality Mouse with a jingle bell on
his neck and you out there Green Mile
and maybe boy you know what I'm saying
dude they used to have a cat circus that
parked around here my ex-girlfriend was
always showing me on the youtubes a cat
circus and two of them they finally went
on Jimmy Kimmel and didn't do [ __ ] and
they got fired but they had nine cats
living in a purple van doing nothing you
know and so anything's possible but I
feel you man when it's maybe you just
have to step away maybe get you one
animal and hit the road with it you know
Marcus is special uh Marcus and his
special beagle you know the supernatural
the supernatural aardvark and you don't
want to see me with it with social media
these days you could advertise in a lot
of special ways people are doing
everything you could go sleep with the
UM sloth
they got sloth sleeping they got sloth
sleeping over there and all your
valuables are safe because it'll take
that thing about in eight hours to steal
your phone because it's so slow but you
could sleep with a sloth you go up in
there and they got this little cubicle
you and your buddy in there and y'all
can sleep with a slot if you
one for 200 over there outside of
Portland but there's a lot of different
opportunities meant a lot of ways to
make Animalia more comfortable and I
think a lot of these things are gonna
change them and go to Texas you do you
you meet the right neighbor they'll have
a damn tiger in Texas they'll have two
white tigers out there there's a lot of
different stuff going on but good luck
out there daddy and if anybody has any
suggestion for the zookeeper - how to
how to stay in the animal game even if
you're you know you're kind of quacked
out hit the hotline ninety five six six
four nine five zero three and if your
quacked out of anything i want to let
you know that this episode is brought to
you by better help better help will
assess your needs and match you up with
your own licensed professional therapist
you know I've talked about it on here if
you need therapy you need help then
better help is a great place to do it
it's a place where you know sometimes
learning to talk to someone and get some
help for your brain and get back into
your body it's hard it's hard at first
it's hard to get the practice it's hard
to just do it better help is a great way
to experience professional help there's
a broad range of expertise in better
helps counselor network which may not be
locally available you can log into your
account anytime and send a message to
your counselor it's committed to
facilitating great therapeutic matches
so better help makes it easy and free to
change counselors if needed better help
wants you to start living a happier life
today visit better help.com slash Theo
that's better
h ELP dot-com / Theo and join the over
half of a million people taking charge
of their mental health with the help of
an experienced professional and our
special offer for this past weekend
listeners 10% off your first month your
first month not your first visit your
first month at better help calm / Theo
you can FaceTime with the counselor you
can just um you can talk on the phone
you could talk regular you could text
it's a great way to experience
just checking in with yourself and
checking in with somebody else to check
in with yourself
let's get another call here here we go
thank you for supporting and also we got
this Rat King hitter I'm wearing it
right now we got a lot of neat stuff out
there Rat King t-shirt that I really
loved that my brother wears a lot I see
him wearing on Facebook and really means
a lot to me that he wears it I know he I
mean because he's businessman and and uh
and it's the year of the rat baby you
know I'm making that come back all these
clams dude I'll see him in the chowder
baby I was raised
kissing oysters son let's go see oh this
is Austin I need some advice every time
me and my girl order takeout she find
something wrong with her food weather is
the hair or something doesn't look right
and she ends up making me take it back
Oh yo here's a uh-huh it's dude if you
gotta say let's hear more should I just
not beat her butter eat my scrap or do I
just eat you fat and this other stuff is
in my food man look I think there's
nothing I can't stand more than somebody
who sends their food back all the time
unless that thing came with you no I say
two hairs or more one hair I'll have it
but a sideburn I'm sending that [ __ ]
back you know let Andra got one of them
Rapunzel braids in there I'm sending
that [ __ ] back but one hair - hair red
hair blue hair you know somebody drop
half an ante for wig and that thing I'll
still have it I'll still have it you
know life is life things are going to
happen but if you have somebody that
sent in food back I'm just saying how
will they one day just send you back
maybe she finds a hair on your shoulder
maybe she finds an ingrown hair whose is
this huh
like that's mine whatever I'm out so you
got to think about you got to think
about that man I can't stand that for me
that's a buzzkill if it happens once in
a while - service is bad or something
yeah I could see raising hell I went
over to a pizza place man I swear if Ida
had a Beretta on me broader popped off
in that much and the guy was a complete
[ __ ] in there but I look the world do
justice to him I don't need to do all
that but if you got an N cell like that
living in your place bro and send him
back decent pies because maybe one of
the pepperonis looks like it's winking
at her or something or somebody carved
the Jesus Christ in it a cheese or
something gee jeepers buck oh you better
than that bro but good luck out there
man that's all I got for you dude I got
to be honest with you gang what's up E
oh there's max frost calling in from
Sydney Australia Oh max frost from
Australia thank you for calling man and
um and after all that fire you guys
could use max frost I mean you're
exactly the solution of it I bet man I
hope everybody's doing well it's crazy
like you know we see a million pictures
of koalas you know starving and using
water and stuff and then suddenly it's
off the radar but um but just letting
you know man thinking of you hope you
guys doing well gang homework obviously
I'm not from Sydney Australia I'm
actually Texas I'm down here right now
doing some shows are you just a visitor
that's called a visitor buddy
homeward pointed reason I'm calling man
it's um I'm down here and live my life
anomic music and dine you're playing
shows and have a show tonight that I
guess was good but I guess I just kind
of called in to say like I don't know
there's something about that voice you
talk about where you say like whenever
you get offstage
it was like your brain won't allow you
to
except that you did a good job so just
um about that I really relate to you man
and I [ __ ] I wish I could thought you
know I hate showing up to do what I came
to do and then getting off stage and
feeling like like even though I did it
it's like I can't allow myself to
appreciate that it's happening hmm which
is stupid
[ __ ] man that's it hope you Debra can
get game bro thank you for calling man
yeah man Wow bro okay yeah it's you know
one of the reasons I mean I've done it
my whole life man nothing you know I'll
never be good enough for me man and I
don't know how that happened to me I
don't know how that you know I don't
know how that got inside of me but man
that's a devilish thing to end up inside
of you and I'm not saying that to have
any self pity you know I'm I'm at the
age now I'm able to recognize it and I
can do things to help myself but but um
you know it gets hard on the on the
podcast nose because it's hard for me to
reflect on myself without sounding like
a crybaby a lot you know I don't want to
have self-pity but I do want to be able
to share what I share things share
something if I can you know but no man
it's it's crazy that out that uh isn't
that crazy that somehow we will never be
enough for ourselves man it's such a
it's such a handicap in it it's such a
and it's not true it's not even real
I don't know how that engine gets
started inside of us I'm trying to think
about it and feel about it right now why
am i never enough for myself
you know I will never be enough for
myself why why why why am I never enough
for myself man I'm just trying to feel
I'm trying to sometimes I can almost
feel an answer like inside of me but I
don't know what the words are because
the feeling hasn't met with my brain
exactly so I'm just trying to feel this
out you know why yeah how nice it would
be to have something inside of myself
that's like hey you man great job hey
you did great
hey you should be proud of yourself hey
you should hey man where'd it go because
when you think about it from the out
from an outsider's perspective how how
sad that somebody's walking around they
will never be enough for themselves that
their best will never make them feel
good it doesn't sound like that it
sounds like there's something off there
because it's not real it doesn't
factually check out you know sometimes I
think some of that is the total is the
total is the toil of being an artist you
know there's something inside of people
that want to do order that you I think
you want some of that because it drives
you it makes you adjust and change it
makes you it makes you keep pressuring
to create something good you know you
don't want to just play some garbage and
be like oh that's great
but I think sometimes for myself if that
voice is it's in it's everywhere in me
that I'm never gonna be enough you know
I got the legs of a seat you ever seen a
senior citizen drop their towel on
accident and you see their legs that's
what I have though I have like one
type of legs but if that man was like it
a striker and like a like head like was
but strong I have like strong dropped
towel senior-citizen legs yeah but it's
always everything I see by myself is
never enough it's never good enough and
not a little fit no I don't think anyone
ever told me that I was bad I think just
nobody ever told me that I was okay that
everything was that it was enough you
know oh yeah oh yeah may your yeah
that's good you know okay that's you've
been you know and those are things
happen when we're young it has to have
when we're young but when we get old you
know we can start to plan some different
sees man to bring this back here you
know and we can start to do we can start
to recognize it you know what I'm glad
you called about this because I think
it'll just make me think when I get off
stage or when I get done with this when
I get done with my workday anybody out
there if you drive them FedEx are you
making a you know you're doing beef
scallions or whatever you a butcher you
were barber you doing sideburns are you
doing siding construction it's yes like
when you get done this if I can you know
I did good to remind ourselves we you
know that we did good if we did if we
did try we did try our best you know
[Music]
yeah I don't know man it's really
interesting now it's really interesting
why somehow we're never enough for
ourselves man and I think that's like
the core of whatever it is if we could
solve that in humans and some of that's
always going to be there because there's
this you know that's why people look for
a higher power that's why people seek
that's why people travel that's why
people you know start families because
they want to look they want to fill in
because in the end humanity being human
it's it's a
it's just it's a journey of finding more
at least I hope it is for people maybe
some people are just perfectly happy and
they're already you know they were born
on the pinnacle of peace but I think for
a lot of us it's trying to find out
what's going on how do we what do I do
what can I do to feel more to find more
to achieve to try to what is here in
this world on the outside and on the
inside you know where's the Mount
Everest you know out here outside of
mean where's the Mount Everest inside of
me where's the where can I go in here
command it gets wild inside of us is
deep in there and it's high and it's far
so I think some of that's just the toil
of being an artist man and I think some
of it is it's a journey that we're on
you know what some of it is that we're
too hard on ourselves and that we're
doing okay you know the best thing I
sometimes I can say for myself as always
just said I tried my best but yeah it's
good man I want to think about that more
for myself and not think about it I just
want to start to behave like it hey man
you did a good job
often times I don't want to do it
because I don't want people to think
that I'm full of myself it's I think
sometimes it comes back to I'm worried
so much about what other people will
think maybe I don't want people to think
that I'm so full of myself but thank you
for that call man and thank you for that
question
and keep on playing the hits man we got
a patreon question that came on that
came in uh tawny T o ni v Tony could be
tani favorite TV show currently I really
love the pharmacists on Netflix and I
want to see about maybe having that
gentleman come in as a guest it's really
a great show I really love live PD and
if you haven't seen live PD man it's
great it's like cops cops actually is
really good too
it's just like new cops I like Flint
town on Netflix
I like what else Jim Gaffigan was on he
has a special on Amazon that's really
good and those are things I guess that
I'm currently watching there's a new
Dateline - that's crazy good about -
some people that have two children that
people that they can't find units in
Idaho that [ __ ] is good and I don't want
more people to die in the world but we
need some more date lines boy speaking I
do here's one our California kids that
bad
does Idaho need to build a wall and
that's from chem chickens from patreon
um you know I don't think California
kids are bad man there's there's bad
people everywhere you know there's a lot
of great people in California's a lot of
wonderful people I think the taxes are
way too high I think that they are too
is I think that it's too idealistic I
think the ideas of a perfect humanity
are starting to collide with the
realities that we can't do all of this
we don't or we just aren't you know it's
like I mean the parks are getting busier
I was just looking at a park yesterday I
was going to look for a park to just
chill out and and I went to a park and
I'm like man this isn't even place you
can relax anymore you know this this is
there's you know there's a lot of people
were you know how you know I don't want
to just say homeless but not well and
people that are doing drugs and and I
know some of those people are my people
I get it bro you know the rats like me
you know but it made me scared to just
want to take a nap in the park because I
don't want to get killed during a
sleeping so so I think you have some of
that [ __ ] I think you got more of a soft
batch overall you know and I put that up
you go SEC against the pac-10 do pack 12
pack 20 pack it up as
much as you want they'll never take that
CC man but I just think some of its city
living is different so I think maybe Los
Angeles is uh it's just a tough place it
seems like to raise kids to have you
know every every street is a busy street
there's no space for a child's
imagination I don't feel like you know a
child needs to be able to look out at
some space and be like oh what could
happen here so it's probably a great
place like raising accountant but is it
a great place to raise somebody with a
wild imagination
I don't know I don't think it would be
my ideal place gang um let's take I
think we did good today
I think we did good oh well here's one
right here actually one more patron from
cigars JA Jha Thea what's the best part
about spring gang gang hmm I think the
best part about spring is its kind of a
reminder of what everyday is you know
every day is a new chance it's that you
know every day is a silver medal you
know every day is saying hey if you
didn't if it didn't happen yesterday if
you didn't do it right if you didn't do
it as well as you wanted to it's really
a real soft way of saying here's another
opportunity you know here's another shot
today and it really the way that the
world even presents a day to you is
really so beautiful you know slow
sunrise the light slowly gathers
wouldn't be crazy if just BAM they cut
it on as fluorescent as [ __ ] you just
felt like an ICU or something just that
would be so drastic but the way that
nature says hey I'm here you're here
let's see what we could do the way that
nature
that with just a day I think is
beautiful in spring I think is like that
and I do think there's some value to
live in a place that we you have Four
Seasons because you you remember that
you're part of earth you're part of this
you're part of life whereas sometimes in
California is just the same day forever
it just never ends man so I think the
best part about spring is just as a
chance to put something new in the
ground you know to try something
different you know it's crazy all the
things sometimes that I feel like I've
recently have been feelings that the
things that I
it's crazy some of the things that I
fear the most
or sometimes recently the things that
are starting to tempt me the most like
what if I just did those things you know
what if I just got me a house or got me
a wife forgot me uh or not got me one
you got to really have love and
everything but you know got me a dog
what if I did all those things I don't
know I I don't want to let my life just
pass by me just being in this fierce
state or this place of indecision
sometimes I feel like the best feelings
I could have all right on the other side
of my fears you know and that's why man
that's why but what do I know dude I
don't know anything and that is the fact
I'm gonna probably call better help look
I love you guys and I appreciate you and
thank you for being a part of this past
weekend
and we do have exciting plans to do some
unique things for people this year and
be a part of people's lives and uh and
just I'm just excited to remind myself
to get back to what I think is important
sometimes and what is unique sometimes
this podcast about this podcast is that
it's a group effort and that we're doing
something not alone and that to me feels
good man and
that's the sugar bro that's the sugar
man we'll finish out here with this hit
again from Ty nice and who who sent it
in in that magical man from the ether
what is he we don't know he could be a
puff of smoke he could be a ninja he
could be a Tsar he could be a marsupial
he could be a plate one of the tectonics
underneath us we don't know he who knows
man but he makes sweet music more than
words man I'm out of words you guys be
good to yourselves he deserve it okay
[Music]
[Applause]